another Henry slot professor at
Princeton University to his prior to
that Hillary Clinton's policy advisor
today the country with the most
connections will be the central place if
powers derived from connectivity and the
focus of leadership should be on making
connections solve shared problems
connections of course are what seeker is
all about connecting the brightest minds
on the planet to address the most
important and shared questions and I
think you trusting thing as this
approach works see far programs have
transformed our thinking about a whole
range of important question for early
childhood development the social
economic determinism health the
evolution of this planet the genetic
networks
awful disease the physics of computing
and energy transmission and as you will
hear more about tonight a complex
relationship to prosperity fiscal and
monetary policy and political
institutions for Canada truly succeed in
the 21st century it's vital to ensure
that our young people young Canadians
and the greatest young people
see Canada the magnet emeka where
important conversations and connections
are being made to taking place
increasingly through all those from your
children or grandchildren young young
Canadians are globally ordered they seek
out opportunities that management
international idealistic and
intellectual aspirations combined with
the natural youthful desire to solve
practical problems their global citizens
you see a role for camp that forges
international coalition's partnerships
and networks to address the significant
challenges and exciting questions of
their day one of the main reasons I feel
so privileged to be leading teeth are
there a lot of places is that our
original vision going back to the 1980s
was exactly that to bring together the
very best lines the brightest of people
from across our country from around
world to address fun and exciting
questions this is the hole and to this
day in a condition to accomplish this
vision see far as connections and
networks have to go beyond the research
community we need to connect with
like-minded organizations and
individuals around the world to help us
achieve our mission in that regard a
delighted to welcome Laura Lyons from
the bench Center Vanson the new
strategic partner for seaport together
the carts and organizations are
exploring new ideas shared activities
the live the nexus between ideas new
knowledge new science and the world
around us and the neat area our new vice
president surgeon partnerships is now
speaking too many organizations from
across Canada and around the world about
forming partnerships with c4 but you
think the reason Air Canada stop
today we have any very important
discussion as I said with our program
different directors on how best to
nurture the next generation of global
research dealers and we are committed to
mobilizing in college and putting it as
accident this drive the boat research
into action has been central the CFR's
mission since its earliest days as the
global mail pointed out in major
editorial several weeks ago town sees
FAR's programs in population health and
experience based biological brain
development have formed the basis of
public policy of early childhood
development and education in Canada
Australia the US and elsewhere earlier
today and then meeting with seaforth
program directors get a very robust
ideas on its after that's how to fund
research into action to ensure that the
new collagen is coming out of our
programs is put in the hands of people
who can effectively use that knowledge
thank you again for being here this
evening I know you're all busy on your
time our program this evening and this
speech will begin just after dessert to
share or advice tier for our economy
will share machine some new ways which
you can get more closely connected with
these are one of a team and good so
we're going to pretend worth Davos we're
not surrounded by the mountains we have
a dinosaur so I don't know what what
that means but let's pretend this is a
Davos discussion of a topic that is
obviously a huge current interest and
importance and that's the crisis in
Europe as you all know rarely their day
goes by that we don't see or hear
commentary in the media on the debt
crisis yeah it seems that the more
that's getting written the less we
understand it's only bless I understand
earlier this earlier this month Canada's
finance minister jim flaherty warned
that Europe remains quotes a clear and
present danger the crisis has been going
now for quite a while and from a
distance appears to be little progress
to any kind of resolution how long can
they are certainly continue and what
does it mean for the rest of the world
including Canada of course to help us
gain a better on
I think very complex economic and
political situation we're very fortunate
to have three really outstanding
thinkers of three see far fellows with
us tonight our research cluster on
identity institutions in society brings
together academics from different
geographic and disciplinary backgrounds
to bring new understanding the complex
issues such as the current crisis that's
going on in Europe this evening we'll
hear three perspectives of each of our
presenters and then we'll have a round
table conversation before I open up the
floor to all of you and I hope that each
of you will feel free to put your hand
up not everyone have a chance to speak I
guarantee that but I hope you have a
really robust conversation at the end of
our formal presentations the first our
first speaker is Tim Bethenny I'm very
delighted to introduce a professor best
lee who I just met this aging for the
first time he's the Gluskin janovski see
far fellow he's a member of CFR's
program and institutions organizations
and growth and professor of economics
and political science at the London
School of Economics where he's also
appointed as the director of the
Centauri and Toyota international
centers for economics and related
disciplines he's a lot of titles after
his name he's a frequent consulter to
the World Bank and is currently a
consultant to the UK
Ministry of economics and finance Tim's
research focuses on issues in
development economics public economics
and political economy ladies and
gentlemen Professor Tim Dustin thank
thank you very much Alan and I have to
say it's a it's a great pleasure to be
here it's for me it's about 20 22 in the
morning so if I more than unusually
coherent please forgive me I have to
begin know by paying tribute to see far
which is i joined see far at the point
of my life when I thought I'd already
experienced all forms of academic
interaction and learned that there was a
new on through involvement in an
extremely exciting project and I think
the main test for me of my commitment to
see far was the fact that between 2006
and 2009 I served as a policymaker on
the monetary policy committee the bank
of england and i don't think i missed a
single CFR meeting during that theory
they were right in the diaries and
things I cared about perhaps more than
any other commitments that I had now you
have to bear in mind them when it comes
to discussing issues of Europe that I'm
from the UK and we're frequently branded
as being Euroskeptic and I'll try not to
come over that way indeed I am to a
degree Euroskeptic and like but not in
the normal sense that my countrymen are
normally accused event in the sense that
i'm skeptical about the future unless
there are unless the current elite and
policy makers of Europe decide to
fundamentally sort out the very serious
issues it's interesting if you think
about what have been the two images of
Europe that we've seen in the last in
the last couple of weeks one of course
was the European Union was awarded the
nobel peace prize interestingly by the
Nobel Peace Prize is awarded in Oslo in
Norway a country that voted not to
become part
the European Union but nonetheless
obviously expressed their admiration for
the achievement of using ostensibly for
its role in maintaining peace in the
period of existence but the other image
for those of you who follow this you
might have seen had been the riots on
the streets of Athens and Natalie on the
streets of Madrid the displeasure being
expressed by those citizens a distress
as those countries are under a fair
amount of which I think lies of the door
of a project that one has to say there
are serious ? cinema namely the whole
project surrounding the creation of a
single currency in advance of creating
those kinds of institutions which is
traditionally supported currency tonnes
and I'll come to that in a moment but if
you look in the longest scheme of
history it's sort of interesting people
to go back a thousand years and think
about the various attempts are have been
to recreate the Western Roman Empire in
its various forms what struck what
stands out compared to a tense
particularly those of Napoleon Hitler
and others to recreate the Western Roman
Empire is that the European Union was a
project in which this was going to be
created by free association of countries
to build something which had clearly an
economic basis and that was always at
the heart of what was trying to be
created the politics of what was going
to happen
has happened i think we're always less
clear-cut and indeed i'd say many of the
issues that we face now come from the
fact that there's an uncertain political
vision i think there's a much clearer
economic vision and that said the
creation of the single currency i think
is beyond doubt a project of political
force rather than economic thinking in
the sense that if you look in the
history almost any other country at the
point at which it can operate as a fit
as a currency zone it is typically
already created the institutions of
representative government over and a
boat to regulate them to deal with the
issues that come from having a common
currency and equally the kinds of
transfers that are needed between states
to sustain prosperity in a world where
exchange rate adjustment is no longer
open to you also needs have been created
in advance of a single currency i think
most people who were debating the
creation of the euro in the later part
of last century we're aware of that i
think in a certain sense you can say
they've got unlucky they've got unlucky
because the magnitude of the crisis that
hit europe in 2008 was altogether larger
and created altogether biggest stresses
for that project than anyone could
reasonably have envisaged in the late
20th century in the 19 in the 1990s when
people were designing this i think what
people were bargaining on and something
which hasn't happened was there would be
a period of bedding in of these
institutions long enough to allow the
european project to continue in a fairly
measured way and what we face now though
is a series of decisions that are born
out of necessity in an appointed real
crisis because a number of states fiscal
positions in particular are
unsustainable and within the
or currency they no longer have the
ability to use currency adjustment so
adjustments and living standards having
to happen in much more difficult ways
but the fact is some countries and I
mention island we can come back to that
and some of the discussion are making
those adjustments with relatively little
difficulty and fuss and in difficulty
policy for those who are involved in
making them but not in terms of the
Russians and politics and the degree of
protest whereas other countries clearly
Greece being a prime example those
adjustments to living standards in the
absence of currency change are proving
extremely difficult now the question is
what are the scenarios the future
scenarios there are those who think it's
more or less inevitable that the euro
cannot continue in its current form
quite weather has the break asunder I
think is not clear but certainly there
are those who believe it in the end
countries like Greece will not be able
to sustain membership of the euro and
the what we're seeing right now is an
attempt to patch fundamental problems
that will effectively continue to a
point at which there will have to be
some organization an orderly exit the
other second scenario is what we what
we're in now which is a form of muddling
through hoping for a kind of economic
recovery that would allow us to continue
to paper over those cracks and maybe
that is the future scenario but the
third story is the one that we really
need to talk about is resolving the
issues but resolving those issues
requires creating in effect a political
union over and above what has been
created in the form of a single currency
creating a central state a federal state
of Europe which sees itself as
regulating taxing spending I don't think
we're at a point where if you look at
the history of nation states europe is
ready for that there's no sense i think
of a common culture
syrup that's often a preconditioned
creating effective nation state and
they're certainly not a set of
representative institutions to reinforce
that so in many ways the solution that
seems most promising which is to create
a federal state of Europe also seen as
most out of grass and and I hope that's
what we will talk about when we come to
the discussion thank you very much Tim
our second presenter this evening is
Guido Cavallini also a member of CF arts
program in institutions organizations
and growth weed has been a professor of
economics at bocconi university of milan
since 1994 where he was the rector from
2008 to 2012 he's a foreign honorary
member of the American Academy of Arts
and Science a fellow the econometrics
society and a joint recipient of the
Janssen award for the European Economic
Association of which he's also the past
president the main focus of guidos
research is how policy political and
policy making institutions influence
policy formation and economic
performance ladies and gentlemen see
farfalla guidi company so let me also
thank you for inviting me and most of
all things sefer for all that is doing
as Tim said being part of this group is
one of the most exciting and influential
things that has happened in my career
and it's very very grateful for this
these are obstructed remarks by the way
absolutely but where is easier so I also
want to talk briefly about the situation
in Europe taking a more narrow focus
perhaps than the one that theme is taken
and emphasizing that the current crisis
is a mix of two problems essentially one
a problem is the national dimension when
the euro was started until two thousand
eight until the US crisis there was a
huge inflow of money from Northern
Europe to southern Europe largely
intermediated by the banking sector of
the euro area and not all of it was bad
I mean part of the purpose of having a
single currency was precisely to have
integration of banking markets and
financial markets and this integration
took place without integrating property
of banks but investing a lot of money
two thousand Europe now of course not
all this money was spent well in Spain
and Ireland this manny went to feed a
real estate bubble in portugal it went
to feed grow excessive growth of
consumption in italy it brought
convergence of interest rates on
government debt down to the level of
german death so this was very helpful
for italian public finals which however
did not take advantage of this benefit
to reduce its debt in greece did a mix
of all of these things then came the
crisis in 2008 in the US and this led to
at what economists call a sudden stop
and this capital inflow in two thousand
Europe became a capital outflow of
course creating a host of different
national problem so in Spain and Ireland
which had a very sound fiscal situation
there was not a fiscal problem in Spain
and Ireland the collapse of the real
estate bubble led to a banking problem
in Portugal
was the issue of how to finance the
current account deficit in Italy the
cost of that became high again and so we
started having problems in the
sustainability of debt and again in
Greece it's a mixture of all of these
things now these problems are different
and unique for each country so they are
not the same problem but nevertheless
there are some common features with the
exception of greece greece is really a
special situation which may be difficult
to see whether it can remain in the euro
area also in the long run but in the
other countries I think there are two
common features one is that these
countries we're probably wasted some of
the smelly but we're not insolvent to
begin with of course they could be
insolvent as a result of this saddle
stop so in my view what is happening in
southern Europe with the exception of
Greece is a liquidity problem more than
an insolvency problem if you take away
all of this money from from these
countries of course they're going to be
risking insolvency either they or their
banking sector the second common feature
although the problems were different in
these countries is that there is a
spiral of problems between the sovereign
and the banks so in Spain and Ireland
the problem hit the banks and the banks
created a solvency issue for the
sovereign in Italy the main heat was on
the sovereign but the banks were force
holding a lot of bank debt of government
debt and so the banks became also
problematic so these are the two common
features confidence and liquidity crisis
and the spiraling of bank and sovereign
the second dimension so this is the
national diamond
the second dimension of the euro crisis
is the what team stressed the inadequacy
of the European institutions so because
it was not a political union the euro
area was built on a very strong premise
of keeping monetary policy separate from
fiscal policy this was a very clear
contract very clear political contract
along which the euro was founded and
stores it was embedded in the
international treaties of the euro area
now this creator the problem this was
not an issue until things were normal
but in the middle of the crisis this
separation of monitoring fiscal policy
makes it impossible to adopt the right
policies in my view if you think about
what the US Federal Reserve is then to
solve the financial crisis to address
the financial crisis when it starts
buying mortgage-backed securities from
banks or buying government debt of
course it does both monetary policy and
fiscal policy the ECB could not do that
and so if you don't allow the the
central bank to act as lender of last
resort not just words the banking sector
but also towards the sovereign you don't
have the tools to deal with this
liquidity crisis just because the
dimension of the crisis is so large that
only a lender of last resort like the
central bank has the resources to cope
with the crisis and so
to the crisis you now add a currency
risk a risk of breakup which raises
uncertainty investment goes down the
cost of capital for southern Europe
rises and the real economy is hit so
what is the solution just to close my
remarks I think the germs of the
solution in my view we're really put on
the table and approved in June I think
June was a turnaround moment in my view
because you could see together all the
elements of what could be eventually
solution first there was for the first
time an availability of the ECB of the
European Central Bank to step in and
help the sovereigns of these countries
under specific conditions this never
happened in a clear way in the recent
crisis with the same force with which
draggy the president of the ECB has
putted in June second there was a system
of conditionality that was added to the
European Central Bank interventions
which could lend credibility to the fact
that when the central bank would step in
these countries would not become to
relax third there was a commitment to
build the ingredients of a banking Union
to centralize bank supervision at the
European level to use fans from the
European Union this ESN this fund
created with financing from the member
state to directly recapitalize the banks
in Europe so to use European resources
to recapitalize the banks in
and this is crucial because it would
break the spiral the link between the
bank and the national sovereign and
third there were also very high-level
statements about moving on towards
political integration of course with a
much longer run perspective with lots
more ambiguity on the ultimate point of
arrival but it was put on the table so
all of this I think is a step in the
right direction this was in June then of
course in the European way during the
summer there where uncertainties delays
and step back if it is now clear that
the implementation of these steps is
going to take longer and there are more
difficulties it is also clear that a lot
of damage has been done to the real
economy so growth in southern Europe is
doing worse and worse and employment is
rising and so even with these European
steps fixing these issues will take why
and the Greek the Greek problem remains
so the risk is not over but I think we
see in my view the outline of a solution
maybe we can come to Bhangarh to the
other way thank you very much screwed up
our last speaker before questions is
gained Jensen Jane is a member of CFR's
program in successful societies and
she's a professor of political science
at the université de montréal where she
holds the Canada Research Chair in
citizenship and governance her current
research interests focus on citizenship
and particularly social citizenship
Social Policy social movements diversity
and gender studies where she's analyzing
changes to Social Policy paradigms in
both Canada and the EU ladies and
gentlemen see fire ecology
thank you very much Ellen and I want to
echo the thanks of my two colleagues
both for the invitation this evening and
for the opportunity to work with my
colleagues in the research group on
successful societies it as the others
have already said is a a career-changing
and career and enriching experience and
so therefore thank you very much for
this opportunity what I'm going to do
tonight is to talk about the figural
crisis as my colleagues have already
done with great expertise and I'm going
to talk about the political dimensions
of that crisis but before before doing
so I want to just remind ourselves that
from the beginning
and they you and the European
communities before it was always a
political project an act of political
will it wasn't driven by any economic
knee or any other kind of force and the
political decision of first six
countries to act together in the name of
peace and prosperity and then the
addition of the others so that they went
from six to twenty seven since the
treaty chrome so that the creation of
European Union was an act of political
will and the creation of the euro and
European monetary union was another act
of political will and I've been
anticipation of greater greater union
the second thing that I want to remind
everyone and ourselves as well is that
this is not the first major crisis that
this set of institutions of space there
are those who in fact can analyze the
European Union
as a series of processes having built
been built on crisis after crisis and
the capacity of its outlet to resolve
these crises this may however meet one
of the most serious if not the most
serious that it has encountered so what
I want to do is I want to talk about two
particular dimensions of this crisis the
first is the slow pace of
decision-making what we see on the side
of the Atlantic or what we read about is
somewhat after summit there seems to be
constant summits constant meetings of
heads of state either bilaterally
multilaterally so why is that happening
and one of the consequences of that form
of decision making for the resolution of
the crisis and the second is to link
those damat dimension of decision making
a political choice to the more the very
visible mobilizations in the street that
we see on television or in the on the
web or on the page
the newspaper so let me start with the
first one why does it take so long for
the EU to act in what is a a an ongoing
crisis and here we have to understand
the nature of the beast the fact that it
is in many ways a institution or seven
institutions which is soua generous that
they it is not a state and it's been
it's not even a it's nothing if it's not
a state it's not a federal state this is
despite the commitment that's been at
the part of a project from the 1950s of
several of the founding fathers to found
a federal union what they actually
designed was a set of institutions that
would provide protection to member
states to sovereign countries as they
went about their collaboration so it's a
very complicated set of political
institutions intended to provide checks
and balances not from the executive and
the legislators would
with national situations but to protect
the small from the large the large from
being ganged up on the small the various
regions so that was one of the modus the
second was to create at the heart of
these Institute of this conglomerate of
institutions one that would speak with
the European voice a European voice on a
national voice and that's the European
Commission which has is tasked with
speaking for Europe but which is not a
democratic institution it's a it's a non
representative terrific it's a a
bureaucratic institution and as such as
same as in the front to the basic
principles of representative democracy
but that institution was created
explicitly to play a particular role nor
is the EU a an international
organization while it's involved in
multi nut multilateral negotiations it's
not an international
ization so what is it it's a set of
complicated decision making bodies all
of which have to essentially come to
something that resembles consensus so
this means that you have set of councils
the council the European Council
European Union which is made up of among
other things the heads of state which is
part of the lawmaking apparatus of the
Union you have another 10 which is
pretty which is presiding over by any
the country that has the presidency for
six months at that time so you can
imagine that there's a great deal of
slippage in there if it's a country with
expertise with capacity you might get
one set of results of it's a small
country a new member state you might get
another set of results besides the
Council of Europe there's the European
Council they didn't spend a lot of time
thinking up names so there's a the
European Council which is not part of
the lawmaking body but which is a key
strategic actor which is presided over
by the Predators own president and now
Herman but an own fate of Belgium it's
another set of decision-making points I
am and then you have a the Commission
with its recommendation powers you have
the Parliament you have within the count
within the European Council you have the
group of Heroes own countries because
not all Member States on our members of
the eurozone all of this means what it
means first of all it's not very
transparent to the ordinary citizens not
very transparent to us I had to bring my
notes it's not after my one-minute a
presentation very transparent to you so
that's one problem is not transparent
but the major problem is on there the
major problem is the fact that it takes
an awfully long time to come to a
decision it's a very slow-moving
intergovernmental body which has not
simply the protections of the bank
that'd be a pretty talked about but also
a very slow-moving way through
negotiations to come to decisions so
that this means that the possibilities
of veto points are very strong we saw
this and we see this with the German
physicians often but until now this very
awkward set of institutions chugged
along it wasn't very pretty it was
really hard to teach about but it seemed
to be working this is the Christ and it
developed a certain number of practices
which also helped it to work one of
these was they with what we call it live
assigns the franco-german couple this
was a collaboration between France and
Germany and negotiations between France
and Germany that kind of surround and
they formal discussions again and
produced a consensus at least with those
two large actors when that's broken it
becomes much more difficult to move
forward and this is one of the things is
characterizing this crisis it also
developed other norms some of which were
not particularly helpful they prime
minister of Luxembourg and the current
head of the eurozone group
so impaired describe this in criticizing
his colleagues one day when he said well
you can't expect to denounce Europe six
days a week and ask your citizens to
vote for and on Sunday so that you have
national politicians playing games of
blame avoidance passing the buck and
then wondering why their citizens began
to be skeptical become euro skeptics so
a complicated situation that's what it
takes so long that's why we hear about
it for so long but and this is a very
important but for those of you who read
the New York Review of Books who would
have read allowance article last week in
which you pointed out that even though
it's taking long a long time there are
signs of it moving forward and you've
already and you know what we know has
mentioned those in particular that there
have been two relief packages
proved one into a weight and the second
one through the summer and so despite
the difficulties of the institution
despite the unwieldy nature of the
institutions there is this kind of
movement toward what we can see is a
soap as and potential solution so what
what I want to do it to end in my
informal few minutes is to you is to go
back to the metaphor that's always
attributed to jog the lore that the
European Union that he was involved in
designing with this economic Union prior
to political union that the European
Union is like a bicycle and that if you
stop pedaling you fall off if you fall
off it's much more difficult to get
started to pick it up and go again and
so I think that we can see the last
couple of years as years of sort of
crooked right tipping over but still
moving forward and each day that becomes
a kind of referendum on the future of
the European Union as students of
nationalism
that every day was a referendum on the
future of the country I haven't talked
about my second point so I hope that
it'll come back in the in the discussion
which is what one of the links between
this institutional arrangement these
institutional difficulties and what's
going on in the streets of Athens in
Madrid thank you well perhaps I'll start
there by the way thank you all three
really insightful presentations so tim
you talked about the lack of a political
vision for the European Union going way
back and we know about this sort of
layers upon layers and very complicated
machinery in the absence of a coherent
vision or structures and lack of
transparency so
I just could reason for pessimism in the
middle of this crisis is it going to be
possible to swallow the bitter pills
that are necessary especially given that
countries of the EU are democracies and
so this issue 1 additions to me would be
what's what's the man or woman on the
street thinking about all of this I'd
always not want answer if it depends on
which street in which country but can
you give us a sense of I guess not not
necessary that question but how
democracy and the national level is
going to impact or impede on European
solution to this crisis maybe Guido you
first and then you generate new
restaurant sector so I think it's a
interacting with the crisis in different
ways in all of these countries even in
the rich countries in Germany particular
there are very strong views among
citizens and politicians that want to
preserve the spirit of the Maastricht
Treaty and tie the hands of the central
bank which I think in my you makes the
crisis much more difficult
so this is one aspect of democracy which
in Northern Europe is directing creating
problems to solve but to solve the
crisis I was recently in Spain and
Portugal just a few weeks ago I was
surprised by how pro-european they
remain and you would think that maybe
there are that there should be doubts
about whether it was wise to join the
euro area you don't hear those doubts at
all and maybe because after all these
two countries benefited a lot from
Europe and from the from Europe in from
the euro in Italy of course I know it
better there are many more populist
voices against the Europe against the
euro area the latest polls give twenty
percent of the goal to populist party
headed by essentially comic actor which
is campaign on Italy should perhaps lead
in our Berlusconi and not a stroke
another one
so if you add the
I think but it would not leave the euro
but there is somebody out there who is
toying with this populist party
population and increase too so a danger
of the crisis if it continues is that it
will undermine not democracy I think
Europe remains democratic but the
function E or to look at the institution
because it will make it much much more
difficult at some point to see light at
the end of the tunnel to see home
this opens up their own for this
department Jane piercing anything to add
yeah well i mean i think i think that
the caution about the domestic
consequences that that you've just
mentioned
important to have this nice and i would
i would just second that analysis being
a risk but i think that that there's
also a question about a kinds of
political
movement towards political institutions
that Tim's calling for because I think
that this there's that the crisis itself
is making it more difficult to move
towards those institutions the political
construction because one of the things
that the crisis does is that it brings
it the way that has been managed to
drink some backtracking on the element
of the European Union that was always
promised to go along with economic Union
so there would be there would be
economic and monetary union but that
wouldn't interfere with European social
model that would be it would be the euro
but that wouldn't interfere with the
European social model that was that was
the compact and in fact what's happened
and that's what the crisis has really
done is to ask people in greece and in
spain to give up those those are
acquired rights or potential benefits of
the
of social Europe in order to save
economic Union economic Europe and so
people are being asked to to give up
parts of their pensions or they're being
asked to give a part of their children's
future for employment busy youth
unemployment is sulfur so high the being
asked to do that in the name of saving
the euro now all of that may be very
necessary that's not my point my point
is that when you then ask them in a year
or two to vote in a referendum on a new
treaty I think it's going to be a lot
harder than it had been it's been even
up to this day where we know it's been
relatively hard in some countries to get
positive votes on referendum so there
that needs to be thought through very
carefully by the European leaders sits
in there any any reason for optimism I
think you entered a somewhat optimistic
note so house is burning what what do
you advise government well on this
particular issue if I had an optimistic
I misspoke because in think of think of
the role of the ECB and you know that is
now going to become one of the primary
institutions with its its democratic
accountability it's really quite limited
and so we're and and I was in Ireland
last week and the guys there I had a
very interesting dinner with
senior people the governor said matter
what are they been spending the day
before doing talking to the troika as
they called it the guys who come in and
now give the report card to the Irish
government a popular not a popular thing
but a well-known figure in Ireland right
now is the IMF official becomes every
three months you know this is
undermining democracy you know the guys
in Washington coming to island and a lot
of the decisions can be made of our
people's pensions and salaries and so
forth on the back of this off I'm ready
quite good suit and the third thing
which would give very little discussion
is going to China now and you know
saying what is this done for prospects
of democracy in China they look at
Europe and they say this soon we of
democracy has done you know they've the
I the argument going on inside China
about democratic reform has been set
back like this so anything on every
front I know cabbage this is the second
syllable cell back
good gosh charity hearth board of
directors and someone who was a little
bit of closing remarks data well thank
you alan look what I'd like to do is
invite you loved one really large round
of applause for our panel here
as been shed nearly a million starting
from the old days of European home seal
team was always an active political
wealth it remains very much an active
political well in the real question
which kind of under way they remarks
about a 3-pound listeners is there that
political will there to continue to move
forward to as Jack Morrison avoid
falling occupied their hips aha moving
forward and I think we all thought in
you that maybe just maybe there was
something that came through that would
say well if we gave me one of the
provisions maybe we devote on the bacon
dishes because in fact you've anyways
the banking issues aren't be less to
visit than some of the other political
issue after all the German on the
assembly line is good morning
carcasa doesn't really want to see his
savings somehow disappear each other
super way when waiting for that bacon it
might be that leave it will allow the
other more difficult and divisive parts
to proceed forward and as we were at
æstival plank as rapidly as 1 minus
audigier on the other end one house
that's my circle continues to be upright
and even though there's a hill the
quarry Europeans are going to keep at it
and so I think it's really interesting
one or three cameras perspective they
brought brought to bear on that on that
particular issue letting off some group
I really wanted but this with him that
we're hearing tonight really comes the
dust because we have three of their
brilliant people but because in our part
of this broader community and we have in
two of our C farm programs and I hope
that those of you in the room looks
familiar we'll gotta say some case of
the sorts of things that are done at the
heart in the heart heart is a funny word
because all it really is nervous system
interconnections and the hearts are
really the hearts of our 250r
researchers be firmly every day and all
we really try to do is to provide this
connection but those good at the corner
for those connections RS continue to
provide those conditions we really need
the support of all of us in this room
and so it's mark pitch earlier and their
seats are no the circle is it ideal for
you give on top these ideas
knowledge and importantly support this
institution as it bakes Canada at the
center full knowledge now so I'd like
you all to pick up information packages
on people are you got amber selling at
the end of the evening right pick up the
information packages on your way out I
hope you've all enjoyed it it's been
enormous pleasure for us to add new year
dr. love me hopefully a dinosaur
institution they can overcome please sit
you